Taiwán fija su posición me gustaría
enfatizar nuevamente que si bien Taiwán
no intensificará los conflictos ni
provocará disputas defenderemos con
firmeza a nuestra soberanía y seguridad
nacional y defenderemos meticulosamente
la democracia y la libertad las
declaraciones se sucedieron este jueves
en el contexto de la reducción de los
ejercicios militares chinos alrededor de
La Isla Aunque a decir de La mandataria
La amenaza no ha disminuido Y es que el
Ministerio de defensa de Taiwán detectó
unos 21 aviones militares y seis barcos
de guerra chinos en el estrecho y sus
alrededores según la cartera castrense
11 de estos aviones cruzaron la línea
media No oficial que divide el paso de
formosa China por su parte apuntó
directamente al partido de la presidenta
When mediante su portavoz de exteriores
y las autoridades del partido
democrático progresista invierten el
blanco y el negro para confundir al
público advertimos a las autoridades del
pdp en Taiwán que la colusión con
fuerzas externas para buscar
hacer provocaciones solo acelerará su
propia muerte y empujará a Taiwán a un
abismo de catástrofes este jueves el
ejército de liberación Popular de China
anunció la organización de patrullas
irregulares en la cercanías de Taiwán
las maniobras son calificadas por el
alto mando chino como una poderosa
disuasión la crisis entre bellini escaló
con la visita de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos Nancy pelosia La Isla hecho que
fue interpretado por china como una
grave violación a su soberanía